[موسيقى]
في كارثه الزلزال لم يعد هناك نبض تحت
الارض توقفت الايادي عن التنقيب وهجر
الامل القلوب وبدا الالم ورفع الانقاب في
تركيا اعاده اعمار في سوريا ركام يراكم
ركاما وخذلان حجم الدمار لا يصدق من حلب
حتى انطاكيه من ادلب حتى كهرمان مرعش مدن
من كوبا ندخلها اليوم في الساعه ستون
ونبداها بالعناوين
اغلق باب المفاجات سوريا وتركيا تتشاركان
ذات الماسي سته مليون متضرر رقم مخيف
وحصيله الضحايا غير نهائيه
للكارثه ولانقاذ الارواح كل ثانيه كانت
مهمه لكن ما كان ياخذ ساعه اخذ ثماني غاب
التنسيق
الحزن الممزوج بالغضب او صلاح حزب العداله
والتنميه للسلطه في 1999 وقد يخرجه منها
في 2023 المعارضه تسيس الكارثه
سوريا المدمره من الحرب يكمل عليها
الزلزال شمالها جحيم وللمساعدات متاخره
جدا
[موسيقى]
النظام السوري يستغل دبلوماسيه الكوارث
يهدم المباني للحصول على مساعدات لا تصل
لمستحقيها
باقرار اممي
لعنا في الموت لسوريين لا زالوا تحت
الانقاذ ربما كانوا احياء حين توقفت
عمليات البحث عنهم قصرا لعدم توفر اللازم
لاضافتهم يقدر المرصد السوري عددهم
بالفين على الاقل
نقسم لكم اننا عملنا وبزلنا قصار جهدنا
ان عملياتنا باتت مسار البحث الان
والانتشار
ان فرص العالقين تحت الانقاض في البقاء
على قيد الحياه نادره جدا
اكثر من اثني عشره الف مصاب في الشمال وهم
في امس الحاجه للعلاج الغذاء وبعدها
المسكن المفقود هؤلاء اعشار كارثه حرمت
اليوم خمسه ملايين ونصف المليون شخص من
اسقف وجدران تاويهم من برد الشتاء القارس
ومن بينهم نحو 350 الف مسن ونحن مليون
ونصف المليون طفل في جنوب تركيا
ومقاطعاتها المنكوبه بعد الانهيار ياتي
الهدم لمدن متداعيه 25 الف مبنى على الاقل
بحسب وزير التخطيط العمرانيه التركي مراد
كروم سيتم هدمه غازي عنتاب مركز الزلزال
الاول قررت السلطات هدم بلدات فيها وعلى
راسها نوردا واصلاحيه مجموع المباني التي
سار عليها القرار يتجاوز 8000 مبنى سكانها
مشاهدينا نصف مليون شخص ربع سكان الولايه
القرار ذاته اتخذ في كهرمان مرعش ليمحى
اثر بازرجيك هو البستان مركز الزلزال
الثاني بهدم ما تبقى من مباني صامده لعدم
صلاحيه العيش فيها الصوره دائما ما تكون
ابلغ من الوصف وهنا حجم الدمار يفوق قدره
الاستيعاب حين يمتد على مساحه تتجاوز حجم
دول لكن قبل الصوره ستساعدنا الجغرافيا
تقع المناطق المتضرره بالدرجه الاولى على
خط الصدع الزلزالي في تركيا المقاطعات
المنكوبه يفصلها الخط المميت وحين نشات
بؤره الزلزال الاول فجرا في الرابعه وتسعه
عشره دقيقه ضرب بقوه كانت اقرب الى 8
درجات بؤره في عمق ضحل لم يتجاوز 18
كيلومترا فكان اثره على السطح مهولا هذا
فقط اثر الزلزال الاول الممتد من غاز
عنتاب الى جميع الولايات التي حلت عليها
النكبه شديد القوه الى متوسط الاثر ونرى
تاثيره يمتد الى دول عده سوريا بالطبعه
الشركه في الكارثه فلسطين لبنان قبرص
اليونان والدنمارك احدى عشره دقيقه بعدها
ارتدت الضربه بهزه وصلت قوتها
6.6 درجات جاءت على ما تبقى من البيوت
والمباني ولم تمضي ساعات تسع ساعات ضرب
الزلزال الثاني كهرمان مرعش في منطقه
البستان وتوالت الهزات بعدها في الاسبوع
الاول
1800 هزه سجلت فما كان ليصمد انهار بهزات
متتاليه تراوحت قوتها بين اربع وسد درجات
هنا اقليم هاتاي وهذه انطاكيا او بقايا
بقايا مكانه ثالث اهم مدينه في العالم
ابان العصر الروماني بعد روما والاسكندريه
سوقها القديم لا يميزه سوى المقارنه وهنا
من الصوره الرائحه يصفها سكان انطاكيا
برائحه الموت حجم الدمار مشاهدينا عصي على
الفهم 50% من مبانيها اختفت عن رصد
الاقمار الصناعيه وما كان ياخذ ساعه
للوصول الى انطاكيا اخذ ثمان ساعات بسبب
الطرق المتصدعه ولا يوجد سوى طريقين
رئيسيين الى المدينه هذه الطرق نفسها هي
التي عطلت امدادات الاغاثه الى شمال
السوري في الايام الاولى التي تلت الزلزال
نحو معبر باب الهوى واحد واربعون الف مبنى
في تركيا تعرض للتدمير الكلي او الجزئي
لكن الضرر
يقتصر على السطح وعلى المباني منها
الشاهقه سويت بالارض البنيه التحتيه
لشبكات المياه والصرف الصحي في المناطق
المنكوبه تضررت حد اختلاط المياه الشرب
بمياه المجاري وكم يستغرق الوقت لاصلاحها
هنا بعد الصور والجغرافيا علينا الاستعانه
بالتاريخ وليس البعيد
زلزال ازميت في مركزه مدينه جولتشوك تدمر
نظام الصرف الصحي ونظام تصريف مياه
الامطار بالكامل اضافه الى 80% من طرق
المدينه اعاده اعمارها بالكامل استغرقت
اربع سنوات وهذه مدينه واحده انحسرت فيها
تقريبا اضرار الزلزال المدمر وحينها ورفعت
فيها الانقاض بعد قضاء 17 الف شخص تحتها
فكم ازميت بمساحه 480 كيلومتر مربع في
تركيا في جنوبها المنكوب الدمار فيه يمتد
على مساحه توازي مساحه دول فرنسا مناطق
مهدده وستبقى مهدده بخطر انتشار الاوبئه
والامراض المعديه مع طول بقاء الضحايا تحت
انقط
[موسيقى]
العمليات هنا تتركز على انتشال الجثث
الموتى والمفقودين وفرق الانقاذ بدات تاخذ
شكلا ولونا جديدا ترتدي ملابس العزل خشيه
الامراض والاوبئه وانتشارها
[موسيقى]
مباشره بعد وقوع الزلزال في تركيا والتاكد
من قوته تحول الوقت الى اكبر تحد من اجل
انقاذ الارواح تحت الركام وسائلوا اعلام
من اجنبيه رافقت فرق الانقاذ الدوليه
ووصفت الحاله وقتها بانها ارتباك امر
بالطبع يفسره حجم الكارثه
الفرق اتجهت نحو المدن القريبه من مركز
الزلزال بينما كان الوصول الى مناطق اخرى
صعب جدا طرق انطاكيا المدمره عطلت وصول
فرق الفرق لايام والطريق الذي يستغرق ساعه
واحده فقط متى يحتاج الى ثمان ساعات كما
ذكرنا وهنا ظهر عائق اخر ارتباك في
التنسيق فحجم الكارثه يمتد ل 500 كيلومتر
الفريق الفرنسي حتى الرحال في مدينه
عثمانيه التي تواجدت فيها فرق انقاذ كثيره
في مكان واحد ليقررات تغيير الاتجاه نحو
انطاكيا التي فقط لدى استغاثه صحيفه رافقت
الفريق ونقلت معاناته في انتظار حصوله على
ترخيص بتغيير الموقع
رافقت فريقا امريكيا اشتكى ايضا من غياب
التنسيق الفريق التركي المكون من عمال
مناجم كان دون خبره كافيه وفق الصحيفه
والكل طبعا ذهبت محاوله لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه مثال على ذلك كان لدى الفريق
الامريكي راي بينما كان للفريق التركي
وجهه نظر مختلفه الفريق الامريكي كان يفضل
اسعاف المصابين تحت الانقاض قبل اجلائهم
ونقلهم للمستشفى لانه علميا بقاء الضحايا
دون حركه لايام يؤدي لتراكم مواد سامه
تنتشر في الدم مباشره بعوده الجسم للحركه
[موسيقى]
استجابه مخيبه لبلدنا يمتلك اكبر فريقا
للانقاذ في العالم تصريح اعتبر اعترافا
مبكرا من اردوغان لكن ما الذي جعل بلدا
بخبره متراكمه مواجهه الزلازل يعاني بهذا
الشكل طبعا بجانب ضخامه الكارثه رئيس
مؤسسه التركيه للاغاثه التي شاركت بثلاثه
الاف متطوع اتهم السياسه باعتراض الطريق
الخبره التركيه وذلك بتولي اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ المدنيه لجهود الانقاذ بدلا من
الجيش رغم انها لا تمتلك اكثر من عشره
الاف موظف الجيش التركي اليوم يمتلك
امكانيات اكبر مما كان عليه الحال في
زلزال الازميت عام 1999 لكن اقصاه تدريجيا
جعله غائبا في الساعه الاولى الحاسمه التي
اعاقبت الزلزال بعض القرى لم تصلها
المساعدات الا بعد تدخل الجيش
انشغال الجيش تسبب في مشكله اخرى وهي
انعدام الامن وانتشار الفوضى منظمه اي اس
اي ار الالمانيه وكاله الاغاثه الالمانيه
علقتها عمليات الانقاذ في تركيا بسبب
مخاوف على امن فرقهم التي تعمل في اقليم
هاتائك مدير عمليات منظمه الاغاثه
الالمانيه تحدث عن صراع بين جماعات مختلفه
بسبب ازمه غذاء وماء مما جعل الحزن يتحول
الى غضب ترجمته اصوات اطلاق النار الفريق
النمساوي العسكري بدوره اوقف جهود الانقاذ
والمبرر كان اولويه سلامه فريقه الامن اذا
ثغره او بالاحرى فجوه اعترف ايضا اردوغان
بوجودها واطلقت تهديدات
للاسف بعض الاشخاص اقتحموا الاسواق
والمحلات التجاريه بهدف نهب السلع والمواد
الغذائيه الدوله اتخذت خطوات حازمه مع
هؤلاء وسنعاقبهم بشده الدوله ومؤسساتها
حاضره وتقدم كل المساعدات لكن الى غايه
اللحظه لم نتمكن من ايصال المساعدات الى
بعض المناطق اعترف ان الوضع صعب لكن
الدوله تواصل العمل من اجل بلوغ كل
المناطق المتضرره
الزلازل لا يمكن ايقافها ولا التنبؤ بها
لكن الساعات الاولى التي تلي الكارثه تلعب
دورا محوريا في احتواء الزلزال ودعونا
نعود لدقائق الاولى التي ثلاث الهزه
ونتتبع خطه الانقاذ التركيه من بدايتها
مباشره بعد الهزه الاولى كلفت اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ افاد بجهود الانقاذ
والاغاثه والتي بدورها جندت
9700 عنصر من اصل 15 الفا غالبيته فرق
الانقاذ اتجهت نحو مركز الهزه ما صعب
الوصول للمناطق الاخرى مطاراته جنوب تركيا
دمرت والطرقات السريعه لم تعد سالكه
المتطوعون وحدهم من تكفل بالضحايا وكنتيجه
تم انقاذ
6645 شخصا فقط في اليوم الاول في اليوم
الثاني تضاعفت اعداد عناصر افاد وبدا
الجيش يتدخل تدريجيا
استخدمت السفن استخدمت السفن العسكريه في
ايصال المساعدات بحرا الى المدن الساحليه
مثل اسكندرون التي اشتعلت النيران في
مبانيها بينما بدات فرق الانقاذ الدوليه
تصل المحافظات الفريق الاسباني الى كهرمان
مرعش الفرنسي الى عثمانيه والامريكيه الى
اليمان الا ان المناطق البعيده التي لا
تطل على البحر باقيه دون نجده لليوم
الثالث
انطاكيا وذلك بعد ان صخرت وزاره الدفاع
التركيه كل امكانيات الجيش المتاحه
استخدمت المروحيات العسكريه لبلوغ المناطق
المعزوله لاول مره فيما اعيد توزيع فرق
الانقاذ الدوليه على المناطق بحسب الحاجه
في اليوم الرابع باتت اعمال الانقاذ اكثر
تنظيما خاصه بعد وصول 9400 عنصر انقاذ
دولي عناصر الجيش في الميدان بلغ عددها 25
الا ان اعداد المتطوعين لا تزال تمثل نصف
المنقذين 53 الفا من اصل مئه واربعه الاف
من تم انقاذهم على يد عناصر مدربه يمتلكون
فرص نجاح اكبر من غيرهم
اذا للمزيد ينضم الينا الصحفي هشام جوناي
من تركيا اهلا بك اذا يعني كثيره هي
الاخطاء هناك اعتراف ولكن حجم الكارثه كان
كبير ايضا اذا تحدثنا عن بعض الاخطاء التي
تم ارتكابها هل نذهب الى توقيت اعداد
الفرق للانقاذ على مستوى الافاد والجيش ام
من اين نبدا
يعني اعتقد بان اكثر من ان نقول يعني خطا
بل هو تاخير في بعض اتخاذ الخطوات يعني
تدخل الجيش اتى وقرار تدخل الجيش اتى
متاخرا بعض الشيء لان ربما الحكومه لم
تدرك في الوهله الاولى
يعني حجم هذه الكارثه
قررت ان تبادر بالمؤسسات المدنيه
والوزارات
والمتطوعين ومنظمات المجتمع المدني ويعني
رات بانها كافيه لتدارك الوضع ولكن بعد ان
ظهرت يعني ابعاد هذه الكارثه وبعد ان ضرب
يعني زلزال ثانيا
نفس المنطقه وهذه فعلا يعني صدفه كبيره ان
يضرب زلزلان مختلفان بعد الواحد وراء
الاخر
فاعتقد بانه زاد من
قوه سبع درجات لكن لكن لو تحدثنا عن اجانب
التنسيق يعني هناك تشديد من الجانب التركي
كان حول التنسيق اشدد عليه اردوغان في
اليوم الخامس الذي تلا زلزال يعني بعد
خمسه ايام ماذا كان يمكن للتنسيق ان يحدث
فرقا على الارض
يعني طبعا التنسيقي يعني انت عندما يكون
مثلا فرق انقاذ لنقول خمسه فرق انقاذ
مجتمعه في منطقه واحده
يعني باقي المناطق لا يوصلها اي شيء
المساعدات ايضا يعني تصوري مثلا ان تصل
شحنه غذاء او شحنات عديده من الغذاء الى
منطقه ولم تصل الى مناطق اخرى ولكن كل هذا
ايضا تعطل هذه يعني الاتصالات والتنسيق
كان بسبب ايضا يعني شبكات الهاتف التي
تعطلت يعني هنا في تركيا قطاع الخاص هو
الذي يشرف على شبكات التواصل الجي اس ام
واعتقد بانه قدم اداء يعني سيئا في تجاوز
هذه المحنه يعني لم يكونوا محضرين
لبنيه تحتيه يتجاوزون
النوع من الافات يعني كان من المفترض ان
يكون هناك مولدات كهرباء اوتوماتيكيه لكل
في كل المحطات لهذه الشبكات ولكن ما
رايناه انه ينقصهم الكثير في هذا الصدد
فعمليه التنسيق تعطلت بسبب يعني
تاثير الزلزال على البنيه التحتيه ومنها
طبعا الاتصال وصلت الفكره شكرا لك كنت
معنا من اسطنبول الصحفي هشام جنائي
الاتراك يتساءلون فيما استثمرت ضرائب
الزلزال الاجابه في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
بهذا الشكل وفي اول مباراه تشهدها الملاعب
التركيه بعد الزلزال عبرت جماهير نادي
طرابزون سبورت عن شكرها لجهود فرق الانقاذ
التي شاركت في انتشار الضحايا والناجين من
تحت الانقاض على قبعه رجل الانقاذ اعلام
الدول التي ساعدت تركيا هي رساله شكر بين
زلزلي
وثلاثه مفارقه الحزن الممزوج بالغضب في
الشارع التركي او صلاح حزب العداله
والتنميه للسلطه بعد زلزال 99 المشاعر
ذاتها قد تقلص من فرص استمراره في الحكم
في
1999 قدم الحزب وعودا ضخمه للاتراك
الغاضبين ستكون هناك قوانين بناء اكثر
صرامه وهو ما حدث بالفعل بعدما تولى
السلطه لكنها بقت مجرد قوانين لم تنف على
ارض الواقع او في الكثير من المناطق فكيف
تتم عمليه البناء في تركيا
بسهوله يحصل المقاولون على تراخيص البناء
وبعد استكمال عمليه البناء يجب الحصول على
ترخيص الاشغال شهاده تؤكد ان المبنى صالح
للاستخدام اين تكمن المشكله في التنفيذ
والرقابه الحصول على تصاريح البناء سهل
كما قلنا لكن عمليات التفتيش ضعيفه اذا
كانت المعايير تفرض استخدام 100 طن من
الحديد في مبنى فسيستخدمون 90 طن هكذا وصف
مقاول سابق الوضع
على سبيل المثال بعد مغادره المفتشين
لموقع البناء يقلل المقاولون من كميه او
جوده الحديد المستخدم ثم يتقنون يتقنون في
مفاوضات غير رسميه مع السلطات المحليه على
امل الحصول على عفو ودفع غرامه وطبعا
النتيجه كارثيه والمثال رايناه في الزلزال
الاخير نحو 10% من الم المدمره بني
الظاهريه وفقا للمعايير الجديده
الصارمه لا مفرق من المقارنات مع زلزال
1999 واستخدامه كمرجع عند مسائله الشعب
للحكومه كان امامكم 24 24 عاما للاستعدادي
لهذه اللحظه هكذا تحاول المعارضه استغلال
الكارثه السياسيا الحكومه التي اعتقلت عدد
من المقاولين بعد الزلزال لكن السؤال من
الذي رخص هذه البنايات تنتقد الحكومه
اليوم تنتقد على برنامج عفو الشامل عام
2018 سمح للمباني منخفضه الجوده والتي لم
تلتزم بمعايير السلامه بدفع غرامه ماليه
فقط نظير المخالفات وبالمناسبه القرارات
اطلقت منذ اربعينيات القرن الماضي
[موسيقى]
وتنضج
يرى مهندسون اتراك ان منح المباني التي
انتهكت قواعد السلامه الصفه القانونيه ومن
بنها 75 الف مبنى في منطقه الزلزال فقط
يرونه يعني تجاوز شديد انتقاد اخر
للمعارضه بعد زلزال
1999 فرضت الدوله ضريبه لتستخدم عائداتها
لتستخدم عائداتها في الاستعداد للزلزال
والزلازل القادمه اليوم الاتراك يتساءلون
فيما استثمرت ضرائب الزلزال وهل يمتلك
عمله هاتاي اجابه مثلا
جلال
نقدر
نشوف بقسم
من المسؤوليه فاحزابها تدير عددا كبيرا من
بلديات المدن المتضرره كما انها دعمت قرار
برنامج العفو عن البناء في 2018 لنفس
الاسباب التي اقرها حزب اردوغان حزب
العداله والتنميه اسباب انتخابيه انتقاد
اخر لاردوغان ولحكومته بسبب تغيير قانون
ليصبح الجيش اليوم في انتظار تعليمات قبل
التدخل على عكس زلزال 1999 حين اصبح الجيش
في مواقع البحث خلال ساعات لكن في المقابل
هناك حقائق قد تدعم اردوغان واقف وافق على
المساعده الدوليه فورا وسهل من عملياتها
على عكس الزلزال 1999 الذي رفض فيه
التحالف الحاكم مشاركه فرق انقاذ اجنبيه
لا شك ان زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجات على مقياس
ريختر سيخلف دمارا في اي مكان حضاريا في
العالم لكن حين تتهالك كل الطوابق فوق
بعضها البعض فهذا يزيد من اعداد الضحايا
ويساعد من عمليات الانقاذ فما هي قصه
مباني الطوابق الناعمه عاده ما يتم ازاله
عناصر التدعيم من الطوابق الارضيه ويتم
استبدالها باعمده فقط لخلق مساحات كافيه
للمحال التجاريه وهنا المشكله الاولى في
الطوابق الارضيه الاعمده وحدها تكون في
الغالب غير قادره على امتصاص الاهتزازات
ثاني مشاكل هذا التصميم تكمن في ان الطابق
الارضي يحتوي على جدران اقل من باقي
الادوار وهو ما يترك بعض الجدران في
الطابق الارضي غير متصله بباقي جدران
المبنى هذا يعني ان ارضيه البناء اساسها
الذي تستند فيها اضعف من الطوابق العلويه
ولهذا السبب عندما تهتز الارضيه نتيجه
لزلزال ينهار الطابق السفلي اولا ثم تسقط
بقيه الادوار فوقه فيما يعرف بانهيار
الفطيره مما يجعل المبنى معرضا بشده للتلف
في الزلزال الحل اذا هلا يقتصر على هدم
جميع المباني القديمه وبناء غيرها في
الواقع لا يمكن اعاده هيكله المبنى وذلك
عن طريق استبدال الاعمده الضعيفه في
الطابق الارضي بهياكل الفولاذيه او تقويه
الجدران الحامله بحديد التسليح المزيد من
الفولاذ يعني هياكل اكثر مقاومه للزلازل
لذا تشهد عمليه رفع الانقاض حاليا عزل
الحديد والكلاب عن باقي مواد البناء وذلك
من اجل التاكد من مدى التزام المقاولين
بالمعايير اخر تحديث لهذه المعايير كان في
2018 ونص على استخدام خرسانه عاليه الجوده
مسلحه باسياخ من الصلب المضلع من اجل بناء
اعمده راسيه ودعامات خرسانيه افقيه
لامتصاص اثر الهزات لكن هذه العمليه مكلفه
للغايه
للمزيد لا تنضم الينا من اسطنبول المهندسه
المدنيه مياس الشيخ اوغلو اهلا بك من
المشاهد كانت واضحه وبعضها فسر نفسه بنفسه
راينا مباني تتلاشى واخرى صمدت امام
الزلزال لكن عمليا كيف يستدل على الفساد
في البناء بعد انهيار هذه المباني ما هي
الاجراءات وما هي المعايير
بدايه نسال الله تعالى الرحمه على ارواح
الضحايا
على ارواح الضحايا والشفاء العاجل لجميع
الجرحى وان يحفظ اخواننا المتضررين في
جنوب تركيا والشمال السوريه
هناك بعض الكودات التصميم هناك في كل بلد
كودات تصميميه يعتمد تعتمد يعني عمليه
البناء على هذه الكودات التصميميه في
تطبيق شروط ومواصفات والشروط والمواصفات
والاسس الموجوده في هذه الكودات التصميميه
فمعايير البناء في تركيا يجب ان يتم وفق
هذه
وفق هذه البناء على هذه الكودات التصميميه
نعم لكن بعد انهيار هذه المباني كنت اسالك
عن المعايير وعن الاجراءات التي يستدل من
خلالها على وجود فساد راينا اعتقال
المقاولين ولكن كيف يستدل على الفساد بعد
انهيار المبنى
بعد انهيار المبنى يستدل على الفساد من
الاعمده مثلا كميه عدم وجود كميه تسليح
كافيه
[موسيقى]
يعني حتى تتحمل العناصر الانشائيه تتحمل
هذه القوه الزلزاليه
المطبقه عليه الواقع يعني في هذا المحاصله
بالاضافه الى من خلال مثلا الشقوق الظاهره
التشققات التي تظهر بعد بفعل القوه
الزلزاليه يتبين يعني عدم الالتزام
بالمعايير والاسس
الواجب تطبيقها في يعني في ضمن القضاه
التصميميه الموجوده في ولذلك يتم جمع
الحديد من المباني المنهاره لدراسه عددها
ونسبتها من البناء اشكرك جزيل الشكر كنت
معنا المهندس المدنيه مياه الشيخ اوغلو من
اسطنبول
داخل اللجوء ويتامى يزيد عددهما في سوريا
في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في الوقت الذي يصادق فيه
رجال الانقاذ الزمن للعثوري على نجينا بين
انقاض الزلزال هناك من يسعى للكسب السياسي
من الكارثه النظام السوري يرى مراقبون ان
النظام يضغط من اجل ارسال مساعدات خارجيه
عبر الاراضي السوريه للتحرر من العزله
الدوليه المفروضه عليه هذه المساعدات لا
تساعد المتضررين من الزلزال بل تساعد
النظام نفسه ووسائل اعلام سوريا ووسائل
تواصل كثيره تحدثت عن بعض المساعدات
المكتوب عليها غير مخصص للبيع او برنامج
الغداء العالمي انتهى بها المطاف معروضه
للبيع على صفحات فيسبوك او متاجر تابعه
لبعض الموالين للنظام فتاه سوريه تدعى
ديما ابو اسماعيل وفقت عمليات بيع
المساعدات كما نتابع هنا وكثيرون على
مواقع التواصل خرجوا وفضحوا استغلال
النظام كارثه الزلزال وبعضهم كان مصيره
الاعتقال مثل الناشط معين علي في اللاذقيه
المساعده وحصران لازم تروح على مبنى
المحافظه ليش مبنى المحافظه ليش لا حتى
اسلم على غيري امانات محطوطه برقبتي انا
مين انت لحتى سلمى
حضرتك لحتى اسلمك انا مين ما كنت تقول
الوضع في شمال سوريا تجاوز وصفه بالكارثي
الى ما هو اعمق من ذلك سكانه علقوا بين
الموت تحت الانقاض والتجمد في ظل البرد
القارس بينما يفتقرون للحدود الدنيا من
البنيه التحتيه والصحيه والمدنيه التي
تسعفهم في مواجهه هذا الدمار الوقت الذي
تلا الكارثه كان الاكثر اهميه فجاءت كارثه
فوق كارثتين الاولى الحرب التي افقدتهم
ابسط مقومات الحياه طوال 12 عاما والثانيه
زلزال مباغت اتى على ما تبقى ليحصد الاف
الارواح والحصيله النهائيه مخباه تحت
الركام وفوقها 11 مليون متضرر في محافظات
حلب وادلب واللاذقيه الاكثر تاثرا
بالزلزال بجانب حماه وطرطوس حلب الواقعه
على بعد 155 كيلو مترا من مركز
القهرمان مرعش التركيه اكثر من 400 الف
فيها باته في العراء
مشاهدينا هذه مدينه الاتارب وهذه بلده
جنديرس التي سجلت وحدها اكثر من الف قتيل
تعرض 70 في المئه من مبانيها للدمار
والمشاهد استنسخت ايضا في ادلب ارمناز
وسلقين حارم وعزمرين اختصار تحولت المدن
المنكوبه الى اراض خوت من كل شيء عدا
الركام والموت والعوز والكارثه الثالثه هل
من مغيث
اليوم الخامس بعد الزلزال اول قافله
مساعدات تدخل من معبر باب الهوى من الجنوب
التركي خلت من الخيام والغذاء او قافله
الثانيه بعد اليوم السابع حملت مواد ايواء
مجدوله وليست اغاثيه للزلزال اما النجده
الحقيقيه فجاءت في اليوم التاسع وذلك بعد
فتح معبر باب السلامه الموصد منذ 2020
جراء ضغط روسي على مجلس الامن الدولي ادى
الى تعديل اليه ايصال المساعدات عبر
الحدود
مسؤولون في منظمه الصحه العالميه زاروا
حلب المدمره بعد ايام من الزلزال وطلبوا
من رئيس النظام السوري فتح المزيد من
المعابر الحدوديه
لضمان توصيل المساعدات
وقبل
[موسيقى]
ماساه لا تفاقم قسوه الماساه في سوريا
ضحاياها فقراء في مناطق سيطره نظام وايضا
فقراء في مناطق كانت تقصفها طائراته شمال
البلاد وحتى بعد الزلزال ادلب واجزاء من
شمال حلب بلا سلطه افقر المناطق واكثرها
تضررا شهدت انهيار اكثر من الاف المباني
اما مناطق سيطره النظام طرطوس حلب وحماه
اللاذقيه دمر الزلزال المباني فيها
بالمئات واين يظهر الفارق يظهر الفارق في
الانقاذ قوات تستنفر تحت سيطره النظام
بمساعده الجيش الروسي واياد تمزقها
الانقاض والركام خارج اسواره على المقلب
الضعيف المهترئ الخوذ البيضاء راسه حربه
عمليات الانقاذ شكى الضعف مواردها البشريه
في تغطيه عمليات البحث استغاث عناصرها في
ظل الدمار الحاصل على خط القرى والمدن
المنكوبه الظروف المناخيه ايضا كبحت الامل
2500 الف عنصر عفوا عنصر دفاع مدني
ويكافحون الامطار والثلوج في سباقنا مع
الزمن للوصول الى احياء بين الاموات لو
كان للزلزال عنوان عريض على الجانب السوري
وتحديدا الاكثر تضررا منه فسيكون اللجوء
داخل اللجوء مهجرون سوريون في سوريا 4
ملايين شخص هم في امس الحاجه للمساعدات
اكثر من 70% منهم قبل الزلزال لا يجدون
قوت يومهم بحسب الامم المتحده مصيرهم الان
من البيوت المتصدعه او ما يشبهها وما لا
يحتمل كم الهزات الارتداديه الى العراء لا
ملاجئ تاويهم بخلاف حال المتضررين من
الزلزال في مناطق سيطره النظام ويؤكد انه
فتح قرابه 80 ملجا لاستيعاب من تهدمت
اذا معاناه الاربعه ملايين نازح قبل
الزلزال وخمسه ملايين ونصف المليون بعده
يتقاسم مروها منهجره الصراع الى ما خلف
الحدود الجنوب التركي الذي بات منكوبا
الان هنا مليون وسبعمئه الف لاجئ من اصل
ثلاثه ملايين
يعيشون في تركيا غازي عنتاب مركز الزلزال
الاول تحتضن 460 الف لاجئ حطاي 430 الف
330 الفا كلاس مائه الف لاجئ وبالمناسبه
عدد السوريين السوريين فيها اكبر من عدد
السكان المحليين او يساوي رسميا واحد من
كل شخصين في المقاطعه سوري لاجئ بحسب
مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين فالى
من يلجا هؤلاء في بلد اللجوء بعضهم انضم
الى اربعين الف متضرر احتوتهم ملاجئ
وفنادق حكوميه وبعضهم وجد في العوده الى
الديار وان كانت بيوتهم مسحوقه ملاذا او
ربما لم يمتلكون الخيار عائلات في انطاكيا
توجهت الى ادلب علها تحصل على بعض
المساعدات من المنظمات المحليه اصطدموا
بالمعابر المغلقه في الايام الاولى قبل ان
تفتح لهم باجازه يمكنهم الذهاب الى سوريا
لكن العوده غير ممكنه قبل ثلاثه اشهر على
الاقل
للمزيد تنضم الينا الصحفيه السوريه جيهان
الحاج بكري التي لجات الى انطاكيا والتي
فقدت الكثير من افراد عائلتها فقدتي جميع
عقاربك بحسب ما حدثتينا جيهان في هذا
الزلزال 12 فردا على الاقل احكي لنا ما
تيسر لك من هذه التجربه المريره من فجر
السادس من فبراير
يسعد مساكي ومساء يعني انا بدي اعتذر منك
بالبدايه والناس انه انا عم بحكي هلا
اليوم من من سياره لانه انا خرجت من مدينه
انطاكيا ونحن بالطريق وحتى التغطيه يمكن
سيئه انا متعبه كمان مرهقه يعني لنا يومين
ما ابدا بالبيوت لانه عم يصير هزات
ارتداديه دائما احنا بالسياره او عم نشعل
نار يعني لانه الطقس بارد جدا
بالشارع وعم نبقى طبعا يعني نحن نعيش هلا
حاله رعب حاله خوف حاله فوبيا كتير صعبه
بتجي بعد الحاله اللي عشناها طبعا للاسف
انا فقد تعديت كبير من اقاربي بهذا
الزلزال كانوا ضحيه
هنحنا مثلنا مثل اي اشخاص
اختاروا اللجوء خارج حدود البلاد جراء
الحرم والوضع اعتقدنا انه ممكن تكون
انطاكيا هي بلد امن لانها هي محازنه
لمدينتنا مدينه اللاذقيه نحن خرجنا منها
كنا اخترناها كمدينه لجوء لانه قريبه يعني
بنشعر انه ممكن باي لحظه نقدر نرجع في حال
سقوط النظام طبعا النظام السوري اللي هو
السبب الاساسي بانه نحن كنا اليوم لاجئين
والبراميل بفعل الاحتلال الروسي بعد ما
سيطر على قرانا فاضطرينا يعني عشنا حاله
من الاستقرار نوعا ما بمدينه انطاكيا رجعت
الحياه طبيعيه صرنا نرجع نزور بعض ونحس
بنوع من الالم لحتى اجا هذا الزلزال
المدمر طبعا انا ما عندي يعني بصراحه صدقا
لليوم للسماء قدرنا نتفقد عدد يعني لك رقم
لعدد الضحايا من اسرتي لكن سقطت عدد كبير
من الضحايا من الاستثم جيهان حتى هذه
اللحظه كم تمكنتم يعني للوصول لاي عدد من
المفقودين العائله من الضحايا امس اول امس
كان تم استخراج اخر ضحيه من من
فقدنا الاتصال
بجيهان
لها ولمن تبقى من عائلتها
[موسيقى]
هون هون
يا رب يا رب لا
يلا قولي يا رب وصلت قريب عليك خمس دقائق
قولي يا رب
انا جنبك والله
قاعدين جاهزين جاهزين شباب الكل يطلع من
هون يا شباب
[موسيقى]
يلا الله اكبر
يوم الاثنين
حواشي الساعه اربعه اربعه وشوي اتفقنا على
هزه الارض عندي الولاد نايمين بغرفه ثانيه
على الحيطان الحيطه يعمل عندي هيك بالبيت
يعني الاولاد من الهزه قوه الهزه
شو بدنا نساوي
عم نصلي على النبي ونوحد الله
وطلعنا برا البيت
[موسيقى]
اول ما بلشت الهزه الارضيه
خاف هزه قويه بهالبيت شلنا هالبنت انا
وشلت الزهراء معي ونزلنا على الشارع وهي
شالله ولدها
[موسيقى]
الوقت كفيل بالنسيان صحيح لكن المنطقه
تركيا وسوريا لن تنسى السادس من فبراير
المنكوبتان لا تزالا تحت اثر الصدمه حين
توقف الوقت بالنسبه للالاف وبات ثقيلا على
الملايين من ساعه لساعه القاكم غدا في
الساعه 60
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على السلامه